the big friends reunion i spoke
exclusively to one of the show's
co-creators marta kaufman
all about it you know i got to ask you
one question about the friends i know
it's coming
why does everyone keep fixating on that
i talked to david schmember about it a
couple weeks ago and he's like listen
we all want this to happen honestly
we'll do it when it's safe
there's always been the hope that
component of that reunion show will have
a live audience
i can tell you the same thing we all
want it to happen this is a show
it is not scripted but this is the way
this show works we're going to need a
live audience
even if we socially distance that live
audience it really is a huge
part of what friends has been
well there it is the long-awaited
friends reunion for hbo max that was
first supposed to happen in march
is on indefinite hold but the good news
is the cast is still absolutely
committed to making it happen
oh no have i said too much what is that
secret sauce that magic wand
to make them all say yes because of the
25th anniversary of the show
there was a lot of love sent out for it
and i think the cast is incredibly
grateful
and want to give back by doing this
special
excellent that was excellent well i
don't know why i came here tonight
marta is also hoping to get back to work
on another show she co-created the jane
fonda lily tomlin netflix series grayson
frankie
production was shut down on the final
season due to the pandemic
frankie just calm down we have four cast
members
who are older we're not going to be the
first ones back we can't be the ones
that make any mistakes
my sincere hope is that we'll be back at
work in january
but first marta reunited with jane
virtually for a new cw special airing
wednesday women in film presents
make it work jen garner is also among
the 35 stars taking part in the one hour
fundraising special supporting equity
in the workplace since the pandemic
everything has changed
the question is will women be hired back
in a more equitable fashion because i'm
the boss
i'm the boss i'm the boss they would go
to women in film and donate to the hire
her back fund
any donation will make a huge difference
in someone's life